we've seen how to fit regression models
with a higher order complexity in terms
of the the degree of a polinomial the
next topic we're going to look at is how
to fit similarly flexible functions but
using splines and remember these are
piece-wise um smooth functions they can
be piecewise constant if it's order zero
piecewise cubic if it's a cubic spline
and the order typically uh cubic splines
are the the default for modeling smooth
functions but we can use constant to
linear quadratic Cubit okay so as we
might want to use splines in a
regression setting we have um we've
implemented something like the poly
function for using beast blindes and
uh you can construct Beast blindes using
this Beast blind object we've written in
the uh in the islp library and this is a
pyit learn Transformer so you see it has
the same uh interface we fit and
transform and this will produce uh the
Beast blind basis um for uh you know
specified by number of knots and well
whether or not you want to include an
intercept
Etc so when we fit this in a regression
model though we don't use the
Transformer directly we use this helper
function this is like using the the
helper function lowercase poly that we
saw above so we'll fit the same model
with these splines and we'll get you
know we can summarize it again and look
at the individual individual estimates
though for a beast bline the individual
coefficients are often you know less
informative it's really the the the form
of the function that's more interesting
so we'll uh we'll start we'll look at a
plot of um of uh of the Beast blind uh
instead okay so I'm skipping over some
of the details that go into you know how
Beast blinds are
described and we're going to talk now
about natural splines uh remember
natural splines are special cases of
Beast blinds that are subject to extra
constraints and that is that beyond the
the last knot they just are extended
linearly rather than uh cubically so
they look like a b spine in the middle
but they extrapolate slightly
different okay so there's
a degree of Freedom Associated to the
spline which is related to how many
knots so where the the um the the breaks
and the dis the discontinuities and the
D occur so using 5 degrees of freedom is
close to using a fifth order polinomial
in some sense it uses the same number of
parameters as the fifth order polinomial
though it does it in a slightly
different fashion let's take a look at
the regression model uh and actually if
we go if we think back to the plot of
the fourth order polinomial the fit is
not that very similar yeah very similar
yeah yeah uh the natural splines have
they they typically will extrapolate a
little bit better because they
extrapolate linearly you know poly omals
can get can grow very quickly Beyond the
Edge point so that's one of the nice
things about using a spline instead of a
polinomial